in this peaceful town on these quiet  streets something terrifying something  horrifying is coming  what the hell was a wild animal this is  really awful  maybe the worst thing I've ever seen  well was it wild animals so what are you  thinking I'm thinking zombies why you  know the undead ghouls gorgeous oh my  are you in this together  flesh-eating zombies don't joke it's  really really creepy oh oh man this  isn't gonna end well they gravitate  towards things they did when they were  alive called pee  did she just say Chardonnay  yes she did  [Music]  welcome to my world armies I've been  telling you this is all gonna end badly  well that's unfortunate I'm quite  confident of my ability to defend myself  against the undead I can see that  excuse me those are some pretty good  cuts you played some minor league ball  didn't you well a little class a he was  a long time ago  [Music]  you